foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
[Music]
what's up my [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] no I said
it
you're in this you look like you're in
Disguise and welcome to the show
Lifeline there's my [ __ ]
no no no look I said it you can't just
take what I said I said what's up my
[ __ ] and you said you're my [ __ ] I
commandeered it so can you tell who I am
because I got a disguise on yeah who is
it
it's you it's Matt oh okay yeah no he
knew well he knew because he's probably
my brother but they didn't I feel like
they'd know no check it out that's me
now because you can talk about her
I mean wow oh you can do that you can do
a cross eyes oh yeah I could do much
more stuff like that too I'm like a good
Entertainer wow Ricky Gervais and here
we are here Lifeline with me and then
there's my [ __ ] no I said it dude you
did but I commented it we're doing a
Lifeline live show get your tickets
under here at the comments October 19th
it's Matt Dalia's birthday show
get your tickets at watchlifeline.com it
is very special we have other things
going on we are talking to you guys live
because we want to hear from you so get
your tickets it's not just videos we are
going to talk with you anything could
happen
he's my [ __ ] you know why it's going to
be good though it's gonna be good
because then sometimes they don't fill
in the details because they don't want
to say it's certain parts I know I know
and then we we're going to be incisive
we're going to get in there we're going
to say why did you leave this detail out
yeah and then the whole because they
want to see cards they want to seem as
cool as possible it's going to come a
crumbling they want to be like and I
don't know she won't call me back and I
was like okay but what did you do this
is what we get to say this and they're
gonna be like oh I was outside her
window I was just gonna say yeah oh
exactly okay so he is stalker
if you'd like to make a call please hang
up inside
and try again message C4
so anyway dude uh Lifeline live get your
tickets uh go to watch lifeline.com and
that's it dude we can't wait for this
man your birthday show yeah it's gonna
it's gonna be a good one it's gonna be a
good birthday I always feel like I don't
have enough [ __ ] planned for my birthday
you know my birthday's coming up and
like you want to make sure you [ __ ]
feel loved and don't feel like a loser
so now I don't have to worry about it
that's [ __ ] big boy plans uh
yeah and guess what dude Chris he put my
dates up but whoo we put he put up
literally a sold out date two dates that
are gonna be uh after the show comes out
and [ __ ] yeah dude he put up the date
said I don't need yes dude let me get a
telescope too so I can read them dude
put different dates up bring up the
website yeah
and get him some magnifying glasses and
uh
[Music]
dude unbelievable I'll just check my
[ __ ] white snake when you say yes
dude
why did you leave the band white snake
yeah yeah I'll just put it up here dude
uh gonna be in [ __ ] uh Peoria
going to be in Raleigh North Carolina
Savannah Georgia
Tempe Arizona
Denver Colorado Cheyenne Wyoming I heard
it's beautiful yeah I've heard you ever
been uh you're you're yelling you're
yelling okay
uh no but I've been to Montana and it is
beautiful interestingly where I was in
Montana Boston called Butte Albany and
it is beautiful if you understand
um Jacksonville and Lakeland Florida
those are all the places I will be isn't
that beautiful isn't that just [ __ ]
gorgeous I'll be at all those places
it's gorgeous
so what about your thing man I'll tell
you right now though I'm going to take
you know what I'm going to do oh my God
didn't give a flying nice [ __ ] pure
Spectrum gummies yum dude I relaxed I
went to a wedding dude I was chill
ing like a psycho hyper weddings you
know what I mean no I know but I always
hated being at weddings and hated doing
things you know what I'm leveled out on
my CBD okay I went to a wedding you know
what dude I was all game all right
[ __ ] Brass Monkey came on and I was
dancing tell him the [ __ ] promo code
so I can talk so it's under the thing uh
it's in the show notes but you go to uh
the pure the link first pure Spectrum
CBD and you type in code lifeline and
you get 10 off Mark is it Lifeline it's
life codes Lifeline Isn't that cool okay
okay well that's so [ __ ] dorky it's
crazy if you're a CBD guy go ahead and
get it uh so my shit's been
on and popping the sessions have been
pimp and pimping go to matchelia.com to
get your own private session with me you
don't need to blow it up to the whole
[ __ ] wide world I've been given some
crazy good advice people come deep dude
people come out with some serious life
[ __ ] they come deep and you're being
rude because you're texting uh but they
come deep and uh I I help her I help you
all and I love you all if you don't make
a session with me I hate you all but the
ones that make sessions with me I love
you all mattelier.com fill up your time
slot now Tuesdays and Thursdays 1 30 to
5 30 p.m Pacific Time thank you we come
deep you know we come there come deep so
porn
very porny dude I woke up Calvin today
when I walked in well he woke up I
walked in his room and I walked in his
room he goes like this you found me how
hilarious is that I said who the hell do
you think put you here yeah well I found
him he's what is he two something two
and a half you know you're his uncle
he's so stupid all right well he doesn't
understand yeah I understand his ass no
I know that but it's uh it's actually
you know
it's a little weird having a baby uh
having a kid and then going to a place I
get nervous that because bro you look
away for a second they're gone and it's
like it takes an extra every second you
look away is an extra five seconds
you're looking for him so if you look
away for hoops right so if you look away
for five seconds dude that's 25 seconds
and that's just because I'm quick at
math but that's 25 seconds you're like
where the [ __ ] is this kid I saw one of
those and that's perfect terrifying I
saw one of those people exclusive like
they have like the ID Network [ __ ]
people investigates Vanity Fair
confidential whatever yep I saw one for
people the parents looked away for 30
seconds and [ __ ]
he was gone
okay working on storytelling
no these guys know what it was oh I know
I mean working on storytelling [ __ ]
it's called The Usual Suspects okay the
movie was doing it and it was good yeah
oh oh oh oh oh that's what you were
doing yeah
oh wow okay cool all right well so okay
so that's terrifying 30 how do you know
it's 30 seconds it was like the hook of
the show it was like we say it was only
30 seconds that's why I don't believe it
I hate
I hate you and I hate when people do the
thing where they need drugs say I don't
believe that no that's that's my [ __ ]
like you'll get sent to video Yeah and
you'll be like I I don't believe that it
was staged yeah like why do you got to
kill it just like you're never gonna
find out if it was stage or not just
[ __ ] enjoy it you will find out if
it's staged or not how by by actually
doing your own research I'm doing your
own research on an internet video double
chained up you're mad cause I'm stacked
up dude I didn't even notice I didn't
even notice I have a shirt right here I
see it and I and I was wearing another
shirt and I went to go um because I
wanted to wear this shirt for the
lifeline yes and I went to go take it
out of my driver's seat and or I'm sorry
my passenger seat and put it on and when
and when I did that the bottle of water
that was on it opened up and spilled all
over it it's really wet and so I I
noticed it spilled all over after I put
it on my other shirt and my other shirt
was completely all wet so now I'm like
[ __ ] I got two shirts that are
completely wet wet and then I instead of
and then the other one was just gray so
it really showed up so I'm wearing the
more wet the wetter shirt even though it
looks less wet than the other one and
that's the end of the story dude well
I'm glad because that was one of the
worst stories I've ever heard in my
[ __ ] life
I'm glad I'm glad it's the end uh so
that shirt is wet you're saying it's so
soaked I can't even believe it so you're
gonna like turn everybody on and they
notice like a wet t-shirt contest well I
don't know I mean it depends on what you
like Planet koi so so we'll see uh so so
what's going on with you man I just told
you okay well what's going on
all right what's going on you not much
okay cool such a dude
um Lifeline worldwide here we go what do
we have we got our [ __ ] producer here
that came up with some [ __ ] why don't
you explain a little bit of it or what
sure okay
we're gonna give advice to people oh wow
it was [ __ ] in mid [ __ ] you know yeah
someone's choking him we're gonna give
oh it was go ahead he caught me off
guard I didn't expect it okay okay
um I'm gonna present some news stories
to you and
you will give advice I mean it's
unsolicited advices oh it's soliciting I
don't know I actually don't know this
what is it oh this is born on the text
chain great I probably was but I don't
read text anymore we're just gonna
[ __ ] I've retired from reading texts
he's going to show us stuff in news and
we're going to give unsolicited advice
to the people in the news Lifeline
worldwide okay okay let's do it okay
okay
ah this [ __ ] okay oh you saw this I know
this so listen this is crazy a Canadian
go ahead a Canadian School Board is
quote standing behind a trans teacher
who sparked protests after turning up to
classes with giant prosthetic breasts
big round processes uh some students
have been skipping classes as students
and parents alike don't think it's quote
normal and expect the school to step in
and put a stop to this now I can end
this right now
tits are too big dude prosthetic or not
make them smaller this is unbelievable
dude talk about the down step sloping I
mean you take a down step this [ __ ] hits
planes yeah well the thing I uh here's
what when I was reading about it I
didn't really it didn't really land in
my mind the way it seems to be landing
in other people's minds it's become like
a trans activist thing but like trans or
not it has nothing to do with trans or
not them taters are way too [ __ ] big
and the nipples are too pointy at a
school that's just kind of like
inappropriate yeah you
dude also trans people right now see
this and they're like this oh my God
right it's not a good it's not good for
them and they know it you know this is
this is just a bad stupid thing that's
like a side show it's actually a South
Park episode I think also they're
prosthetic you're like you don't even
really have them like you definitely
take them off when you get home are they
not implants they're prosthetic it says
which means that they're he puts them up
she I don't know she puts them on
if they're prosthetic then they're not
they're not implants right the best is
they probably ties them around the neck
you know she teaches workshop and they
got Woodwork and [ __ ] I saw videos yeah
it looks like she's gonna [ __ ] cut
her titty off because it's so big yeah
you know she got two of them too so it's
not even just one
um but yeah I I it's not a trans issue
it's not a [ __ ] uh sensitivity issue
in any way it's just a plain bottom line
let's be real about it them taters are
so funny that like her cut me off at the
very end well the taters are too big
okay but it's so funny that like she's
like at her desk and it's just like
she's knocking papers over and [ __ ] and
like knocking over like [ __ ] there's a
compass sticking out of it and she
doesn't even feel it because it's a
great [ __ ] she's got a peek over her
dick yeah
she's like let me guard your paper she
goes like this with her titties
Double D yeah yeah
[Laughter]
uh all right well get rid of it
and saw him off my wish my issue with
this is that the school board is being
so careful of course they are and
they're missing the point yep you don't
have to be careful like
if this was a CIS woman that would also
be an issue yeah hey excuse me uh ma'am
CIS woman your real titties they're too
big
no I'm saying if someone came in
with the big giant vest of titties on
okay yeah the vest of titties vest of
titties starring Bruce Willis uh it's
just not it's school yeah it's not yeah
it's it's not it's beyond normal it'd be
great it's just [ __ ] like such a
distraction it'd be great if it like a a
a a guy had like such a large [ __ ] and
it was like so big in his pants and he
was like
and he was like drawing on a chalkboard
and [ __ ] it was so distracting and then
he would turn around every time he
turned around there was like a little
bit of chalk on it because it Rod though
against the Blackboard why are you
talking about me in front of all these
people so dumb I had it locked and
loaded the whole time all right um all
right so yeah so cut your titties off
whoops oh just leave the vest of titties
at home and just be a regular ass
teacher yeah dude all right also I love
how all the students they interviewed a
bunch of students and they were like oh
we don't really care yeah that was the
best part yeah so but if the students
don't care leave the rest of titties on
I guess who knows you know yeah all
right all right yeah cool I think we
have another one uh oh we got another
one the new monarch King Charles was
shown signing a visitor's book in front
of cameras at Hillsborough Castle near
Belfast he reacted uh after the he
reacted after the pen he you he was
using leaked on him he was seen saying
quote Oh God I hate this end quote I
can't bear this bloody thing dot dot dot
every stinking time he had problem with
the pen oh yeah I saw this video did you
see the video no it was
so [ __ ] the way he was being well of
course it was I mean I know God I hate
this how do you not know you're being
there's a video being taken if you're in
right well here's the deal
there has always been cameras on him but
now especially so he should have been
ready for this moment and the whole
excuse of like well he's just like
getting his bearings [ __ ] 73
dude right he's been waiting for this
for the last 30 years just waiting for
his mom to finally die yeah and in the
first week he's just like this [ __ ]
pen [ __ ] you know what I mean
this is why I like him now I know I like
him honestly whatever to the whole
monarchy thing everybody's so up in arms
one way or the other people either love
the whole thing or [ __ ] like are so
angry about the whole thing yeah it has
no power anymore it's a [ __ ]
figurehead position whatever the guys
get brought so much money I mean Charles
specifically has brought so much money
to charity and [ __ ] whatever dude get
off his back but anyway it was so
[ __ ] so be less [ __ ] so [ __ ] about
this [ __ ] cameras are always on you if
a pen malfunctions just laugh it off
dude yeah yeah exactly don't blow up in
front of cameras yeah all right okay
cool all right well let's take some
[ __ ] let's do the videos that was
great the real things yeah the real
videos that videos that people call uh
send in to do this [ __ ] remember
Lifeline live we're going to be taking
your phone calls and zoom in with you
guys uh get tickets to that under this
video go ahead October 19th
it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey man thank you belly here I am
from the Netherlands and I noticed
actually you never had a video from the
Netherlands before but I want you to
know here also we are very big fans of
the podcast yeah
and my question is I have a girl that
I've been seeing for a couple months now
and I love her and I want to say this to
her but here in Holland it's more
tradition for the girl to say it the
first time wow okay
um but she's not from here so I don't
know
uh how I can kind of look her into Burns
movie
um saying it to me and then I say it
back obviously so any help would be
great thank you
a movie make up a story about a friend
of yours that is from Holland and he
started dating a girl who didn't know
the customs and he and he was like what
she didn't know was that she because the
custom here is that the woman says I
love you first and then pause and then
say what do you think about that isn't
that crazy yeah yeah
isn't that crazy what do you think about
that and then say do you have anything
of your own that you want to say about
would you like to add anything to our
lives yeah
um I think no way dude yeah just say you
love her no listen you're gonna dry it
up what you got to be cool you gotta be
sexy you got to be assertive and you got
to be like I know I don't know if you
know this but in Holland it is very
custom for a woman to say to the man
they love them first uh I know you are
not from here I also don't give two
[ __ ] about that I love you bro that's
see that's good yeah that was a terrible
attempt yeah getting his accent right
yeah it's bad but that's good yeah you
explain it and then say are you going to
kid huh okay Japanese I think
um yeah you explain the whole thing and
then you say that's the thing now I love
you so much I don't care about customers
also she does come here and give me a
big wet kiss pretty mama so bad you know
what I mean so disgusting um I think
that I something a bad guy would say in
a movie before he tries to kill the good
guy uh I think that the love interest of
the good guy I think that you have to uh
not even say any of it and just do it if
you feel it yeah I agree with it don't
even say like
tradition what do I say about tradition
it's always bad it leads to Wars if you
actually
uh uphold this tradition you are
directly causing casualties of War it's
War dude it creates War tradition is the
worst thing for the planet I think I
think what it really is is it's not
tradition in innately it's holding on
too tightly to tradition yeah can get
you into [ __ ] some serious trouble uh
including Wars you know there you go uh
but it doesn't tradition doesn't
directly lead to the war automatically
you know what I'm saying you're actually
killing people if you don't tell her you
love her but the truth the bottom line
of about the advice is and we agree we
don't always agree just tell her you
love her yeah also that guy's [ __ ]
handsome handsome I think it was hand
okay all right there's a beautiful good
looking guy in hand all right next one
big fan of podcasts love you guys
um so me and my man's recently got
married because he's a military man and
he got orders somewhere else and in
order for us to be together we needed to
be married or else he'd have to live on
a boat wow so okay long story short
we're also in love but long story short
we're married and my parents have been
very supportive and loving and
my mom told me that my brother said
that I'm not making the right choice
he's older than me and my sister told me
that this is a mistake and I'm too young
and she's younger than me and it just
really sucks not to have like my full
family support and I just I don't know
if I should reach out to them or if I
should just let it be and just live my
best life
what do you guys think oh cute cute uh
was that coming out of her that dog I I
think she was giving birth I think that
uh your parents gotta be that's the
thing about love man it's blind whether
you like it or not this may be the
greatest idea in your life it may be the
worst idea in your life but your family
has to support you through it they have
to support you they have to say look if
this is what you're gonna do this is
what we think but if this is what you're
gonna do I'm gonna shut up and I'm gonna
[ __ ] just be there for you and you
know you married you gotta remember who
you love and I don't know how young you
are to know how old he is you can't not
marry someone because
your family doesn't like that person
though no not something right you do
yeah okay yeah I thought you were saying
that that no need to support to be able
to marry no no no no I'm saying the
family this is advice for the family oh
you got to support her got it okay yeah
um what's the boat thing I don't know
about that I don't know but something it
made it she made it sound like the
married men
yeah can be all non-boats oh well I
don't yeah but yeah thank God also made
him a [ __ ] salad also how about this
dude say this to your sister your sister
says you're too young to get married say
well you know what you're younger than
me you're too young to even know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing in my life how about
that you're too young to make a decision
if I'm too young to make a decision
guess who's even too younger and too
young to make a decision you and you're
also trying to do it on my life I rest
my case spin move out of there dude is
her sister younger she just she said the
sister was younger yeah what the [ __ ]
does she know dude uh yeah man I I think
uh you got to do what you want to do
it's beautiful you're in love it's hard
enough to find somebody out there
especially these days during these weird
times
um it's great you're doing it right yeah
don't have any regrets if it doesn't
work out it doesn't work out just it's
not like you [ __ ] up though if it
doesn't work out you tried it you're in
love that's the most important thing she
said in that video yeah we're in love
you're in love [ __ ] try to make it
work if it doesn't work it's nobody's
fault it's just [ __ ] life yep
next one
hey Chris and Matt mouth doesn't move my
name is Joe not moving on I'm calling in
today to ask for advice strapped in and
things to say to a friend who thinks
every girl wants to [ __ ] oh the worst
you know he says it about
girlfriends of our friends no dude it
just makes me feel like
whenever I get a girlfriend what are you
gonna say about her you know is this guy
calling about me it's just kind of weird
and no you know it's a hard thing
because there aren't many things you can
tell to a guy like that without hurting
his feelings yeah that's true fragile
ego any advice would help
I'd love to hear your guys take on it
you know I love the show
and uh yeah wow thanks I mean you know
all right dude well first of all you're
right that not every woman wants to [ __ ]
this guy so all you really have to do is
say hey you know like
if it bothers you enough I mean it would
bother me I've had friends like that
that do that and they definitely don't
realize they're doing it they don't
think if you ask them Point Blank does
every woman want to [ __ ] you they would
say no right well every time someone
yeah shows up in their life they say it
so in effect they do face by case basis
but every case yes yeah exactly yeah so
uh I think what uh you would want to say
is like hey you know like you say that a
lot almost about like every woman that
crosses like comes into our life like
you know like women have taste like why
do you say that about every woman like
one of these women at least is bound to
not actually when I'm sexy so what's up
hmm that the format is a question don't
be like hey [ __ ] you know what
you do yeah no just be like yeah no it's
actually agree with them every single
time
agree with them yeah I'd be like dude
yeah it actually is crazy she really did
want to [ __ ] you and what's what's crazy
is I'm realizing is that every girl that
we run into absolutely wants to [ __ ] you
and then he'll be back on his feet and
he'll be like so what do you think yeah
he'll know secretly he does it too much
and he'll stop doing it you think so I
do I don't know if I'll stop thinking it
but it's also he does
here's the thing biological biologically
men have to think that because that's
what makes them pursue women no nobody
pursues a woman more than a guy who
thinks that uh she likes them because
and that's biological you have to think
that women like you otherwise you
wouldn't try as much and we need to
perpetuate our species
nothing is more important than correctly
reading the room that that is true but
not when it comes to perpetuating our
species
specifically then you don't want to be a
creep that like hits on every [ __ ]
woman because he thinks every woman most
rapidly you don't but when it comes to
humanity and moving our species forward
that's what we need yeah maybe he knows
it [ __ ] cavemen but it's 20 22. I
know but we still have that midbrain
activated like hey man ah yes he's smart
and figured it out dude wow so
unbelievably annoying it's annoying but
it's true you are being not what you
were saying even when it's cold in a
hard way you are being is so annoying
and truthful annoying truth continue
okay continue so I think that uh uh I
think that yeah I think that you should
just completely agree with him about
that all the time that's a lot of work
though not really it's also you're gonna
have more fun with it you're pissed off
and it's so annoying yeah and you're
gonna if you just agree with them at
least you have like an inside joke with
yourself what's up with this friend
though like I remember when I had a
friend like that I was like I don't like
this guy really and then I would stop
being friends with them I like them a
lot and one of the reasons was because
of that because it was so funny to me
really and I'd be like bro you always
think I'd be like no I don't but like
all right
all right but he's uh yeah Different
Strokes you know yeah takes all kinds
you know what I'm saying
um it's pretty vague but yeah yeah all
right cool so next one
so close so hey Chris and Matt what's up
greetings from Germany love you guys I
hope you guys are doing well oh yeah
um there's this thing I've been thinking
about for a long time now and it's the
fact that I'm 21. look at his eyes and
when people ask me if I want to have
kids in the future my answer is always
no
but not because I don't want to have
kids in fact I would love to
but I just feel like the world is kind
of shitty man yeah and it's not life
because life rips of course and it's
beautiful
but um I feel really good oh man kids
are just addicted to their phone they
are having all these mental health
problems you know not to be dramatic
also but
the rainforests they are dying the
oceans the animals man I don't know
what's gonna happen in the next hundred
years maybe Wars because of clean water
man I don't know yeah and it's not like
I'm planning to have kids anytime soon
because like I said I'm 21 but
I feel like if I keep this mentality
um not many women in the future will
want to stay with me because what if
they want to have kids yeah right you
know so since of course
um Chris you had a Kelvin pretty
recently I'm wondering if that's
something you guys have ever thought
about absolutely if this fear is
reasonable
yeah would love to hear your answer love
you guys bye you're the most attractive
man I've ever yeah he's so beautiful uh
inside and out too not has nothing to do
with his looks well he is beautiful I
know but besides that okay you want to
go first or what I've actually thought
that uh recently a lot because you're
responsible to not think that at least
think about it yeah yeah I mean I see
Calvin and it brings me such joy and I
would I of course wanted to have him we
planned on it and we had him and he's
the love of Our Lives
um uh no offense to Matt you know
because I've known Matt much longer but
you know no it's all good you know it
happens well life goes on and what are
you gonna do yeah yeah so um I just
think that uh it's it's it I I do I
think be careful feeling that because
you know it's such an overwhelming
feeling if that's what you decide find
decided and Let It Go but like that's a
tricky thing that could lead you into
all sorts of like uh emotional turmoil I
mean that's the world is [ __ ] but the
world's always [ __ ] the world's always
been [ __ ] it's actually right like in
a lot of ways it's better than it's ever
been so uh you know every generation if
you talk to them they're like oh this is
[ __ ] I thought about it today dude I'm
over there I gotta I gotta I got a
coffee and I go to the thing and there's
I was like where the straws is over
there and the goddamn paper straws and
I'm like this is so [ __ ] annoying
that we got to deal with this [ __ ] and
then I'm the old guy saying this about
this generation and or and it's it's
always that like my parents did it his
parents did it hey the world's going to
[ __ ]
um and I don't know man I mean like
deciding to not have a kid because of
that reason is a pretty if that's the
reason I'm not saying it's not a reason
but just quite the
hard line to take yeah I mean it's
definitely I think it's it's a sign of
uh more responsible person the person
who thinks this through as a
consideration as an as for having kids
or not I think a lot of people choose to
not have kids and that is one of the big
reasons and if you so choose then that
is fine everybody's everybody their
decision to have them or not is [ __ ]
fine I hate people who are like you have
to or like it's so there are people out
there who are like you are being so
irresponsible to have a child and that
is such a first world thing is
responsible to what to happen the future
because of the [ __ ] environment I
mean birth rates are down for the first
time ever but I mean in America no in
the world no not in third world
countries it's [ __ ] [ __ ] skyrockets
oh okay and like I I uh but birth rates
in America are down birth rates are
wrong white people are way way way down
yeah uh and the the the thing is though
none of that [ __ ] matters you you need
to decide for yourself at the end of the
day you can't make be making decisions
for the world ah yes if you personally
care that much about the environment
then it still is about you though you
can't be thinking about the world you
got to be thinking about yourself and
the things that may come how good you
are how good are you at dealing with
adversity like things like this like the
world may change but the world always
changes nothing is ever the same from
one generation to another bad things
might happen and good things might
happen too you really don't know so you
have to think about this though I mean
you're 21 now so this doesn't matter but
as you get to be 31 41 you have to start
thinking about what the future is going
to be like for you do you want children
in that future yeah and so like there's
a lot of different things you have to
think about yeah uh and either decision
is fine but you got to just think it all
the way through which it sounds like you
are absolutely doing so uh and again
you're 21 you have so much time so much
time to make these decisions but it it's
good that you're thinking about them now
and don't worry about it but just keep
thinking about it you know yeah uh
that's don't decide anything yet though
is what I would say right now well you
can't because also it won't matter like
what you decide now when you're 31
you're gonna look back on many many
things and think wow I can't believe I
thought that and this could very well be
one yeah you know what I mean yeah and
also you're gonna have kids because
there's no way I mean dude you know yeah
we definitely will clamor over your
sperm right because you are a physically
mentally emotionally top of the [ __ ]
pyramid in every way beautiful sexy
empathetic uh caring uh thank you wise
intelligent beyond your years you are a
[ __ ] specimen that every now it's
embarrassing every woman who can bear
children will want your marriage sperm
to reproduce Matt with the shut the [ __ ]
up that's talking about the German guy
um
um my beautiful specimen yeah I think
that uh yeah careful uh careful what
you'd wish for or don't wish for bro if
anybody should be reproducing it's it's
you though because you're a beautiful
guy and you're clearly smart you know
you care about things yeah all right uh
so I wish I was I wish I could bear
children because I would want to have
his children okay
anyway that's that's gay but okay yo
Matt Chris huge fan of the show thank
you that's dope um you guys are great I
wanna make this quick I only got one
question for you and it's and it's this
are my pants too tight
they look cool like is my shirt too long
boy or does this does this fit [ __ ]
schmack you know what I mean is this
fire let me know please I value your
guys's opinion so yeah please let me
know bro this guy honestly that
alphabetes [ __ ] in 2006. this is a great
video in 2016 that outfit [ __ ] banged
the long shirt and the tightest [ __ ]
[ __ ] the pan the pants that tight I
never liked it looks like they're
painted on uh
particularly tight I like tight pants I
wear tight pants some of them are too
tight I'm going to be honest those look
a bit too tight it is a little weird
though because you have uh tight pants
and a loose long shirt look a little
look a little bit too much like a bell
you know what I mean right right if you
just [ __ ] up here like if you just
like this will go ding ding ding
um yeah it's too it's too much man I
think but that's your style you got the
long dangly cross earring you know I
definitely said I wanted to do that and
you copied it from me but no no I've
been wanting to do that forever no
George Michael no no no like I watch
so I feel like um
uh keep the earring
tailor the shirt and uh get a little bit
of bag also baggy jeans are kind of the
thing to do now right what it is shin by
the way is that right baggy pants or the
thing now yeah the jinkos remember
jinkos yeah I thought I had a pair of
jinkos I was I never ever cooler than
when I wore jinkos dude yeah I I don't I
need to get bag of your pants I have one
pair of baggy pants and I don't really
wear them too much baggy I'm not in a
baggie I'm in a loose but not least I
mean baggy shirts and [ __ ] puffy ass
[ __ ] jackets baggy ass sweaters way
in baggy pants not for me well but
that's what's in look at go to Justin
Bieber's Instagram you'll see well guess
who doesn't want to follow Justin
Bieber's style well I do I want to
follow Haley beaver style no [ __ ] that's
why I wrote those big [ __ ] Balenciaga
things I want some Haley Bieber [ __ ] I
want to follow her dad's style Stephen
now we're talking is my dad or her Uncle
Stephen Baldwin is Haley Baldwin
Bieber's dad he's great he got a baby
shark a grandpa shark tattoo on his
channel Grampy shark dude [ __ ] follow
Stephen Baldwin uh on Instagram Stephen
Baldwin seven the guy is now a [ __ ]
man of God yep you could say just like
me uh as I would actually be an
understatement as a man of God he has
found God the other [ __ ] Baldwin boys
they all just like they all went like a
firework all in different directions you
know
um and Stephen went the direction of our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ all right
next one
Chris and Matt what's up enjoy the show
very much Chris I saw you in Dallas or
Saint Grand Prairie Grand Prairie which
he called it
um my questions about shaving so I shave
my arms because I'm working on I don't
know a full sleeve of tattoos I think it
looks better when they're shaved okay so
you can seem better
um I also trim up my chest and my
stomach when it's pool season nope
um but people think it's weird because I
don't shave my legs
takes too much time they're pretty hairy
so I kind of have like a half and half
thing going on
not a huge deal to me my wife likes my
arms shaved and my chest and stomach
shaved I also got to keep you know the
downstairs trimmed up and looking nice
um but just wonder what you guys think
is it weird that I shave half and not
the other halfway at all uh Let It Grow
yeah I guess let me know what you think
bro this guy's a good looking guy if he
just let it go he would be [ __ ] so
smoking Let It Go I mean the sleeves I
understand because it's like you want
the tattoos to show no I'm saying I
understand okay I wouldn't do it yeah at
least you're shaving your chest come on
yeah what are you doing Chester is the
thing dude my question is do you want to
be smoking
I mean I he probably does want to be
smoking do you want to be smoking or you
want to be a good looking dude you're a
good looking dude bro you want to be
smoking let that [ __ ] go out and your
girl bro she thinks she likes it bro she
thinks she likes it but when you come in
like a [ __ ] beast let her go away for
two weeks and then come back and you
come out here just [ __ ] you got just
straight up like you know puffed out
here and just even let it grow and
they'll do it she'll be like oh
you're asking her when she's not
ovulating ask her when she's ovulated
you know ask her when she's ask her when
it's that time when the eggs are
dropping ask her when it's that time hey
should I shave my chest she goes I don't
know me bro I'm telling you man
keep the hair chest hair is not a thing
to shave Chester is a thing to value and
protect okay you don't get rid of it to
get rid of it is a is a is it's a
sacrilege it is a it is a it is a it is
a sin it is one of the Ten Commandments
if you're religious who's the eleventh
God said
do not shave your chest God said and
that was when God came down to earth and
said ask him when they ovulate him oh
ask him the three days when they're
ovulating
sperm lives for 48 hours
I love that fact when they when you when
you splurt your nut batter inside of
them it needs to be a day earlier than
the three days or the sperm will die
don't ever say nut batter again
okay it's better than
sperm which is what your sperm is like
the actual you're not [ __ ] Bill Nye
dude not batter is what people in
fraternities say in like the Midwest bro
check it out come visit my room I have a
black light in it when you turn the
black light on you can see the nut
pattern all over my sheets
absolutely not going to hell
going to hell
oh yeah yeah dude yeah all right well
yeah ask him when they're ovulating
leave the leg hair leave the chest hair
arm hair or whatever do your [ __ ]
thing that you want to do about the
tattoos but uh also shave this
that maybe it has to go yeah that's a
that's a terrible yep the soul patch oh
no has to go has to stay has to stay has
to stay
whatever you want I Hokey Pokey do the
hokey pokey a baseball a third base
coach
all right cool next
what's up Chris and Matt how do you like
the show my name John and uh I'm from
South Africa but obviously I'm sure
Chris probably picked that up already
with his incredible right the radar
accent skills um so I have a little
thing that I've always worried about
well not worry your penis just one I was
gonna say
um whether I'm actually being a dick or
not but when someone dies oh
and
people you know they post things on
Facebook or Instagram or whatever or
social media you know that's fine that's
their way to grieve you know they're
it's an outlet for them to to to release
some of their grief you know and I get
but when you get like two or three years
down the line and you see people posting
on social media saying like writing open
letters to the person who passed away is
if they're going to read it yeah
still using this Outlet like
it for me sometimes it feels like
they're using the person's death as a
way to draw attention to themselves yeah
which I feel is kind of shitty yeah but
obviously you know
I've had people in my family die I've
never felt the need to write letters out
in public because I feel like why it
makes no sense you know but uh if I'm
being an [ __ ] please feel free to
tell me and uh yeah would love to get
you guys opinion I mean thank you very
much love you guys so much thank you
great day people need to grieve in
different ways I get it if you want to
post a tribute when it happens but any
after that maybe a year after but like
when you're writing
all the time it's like dude hey get over
it publicly at least I mean I don't know
if it's a family thing I get it ongoing
but dude if it's like for Chris Cornell
right which happens all the time David
Bowie [ __ ] like that is just like what
are you doing you're just expressing
your fandom you don't like can't
possibly like grieve their death three
four five years on if it's your [ __ ]
beloved uncle or parent or child I
[ __ ] get it it's still like too much
but like you said people grieve in
different ways yeah yeah so I don't ever
have a problem with like missing you dad
like five years on whatever it is that's
fine but that yeah the celebrity thing
is not but also like a little thing
I don't know though man like I I you
know when I see stuff for somebody's
like people who die tragically or pull
you know or like too young then I kind
of get it you know if they were so it's
like oh you would have been this age
today you know yeah but like if you're
like you're people do like your grandma
like she was like [ __ ] 98 it's like
dude you lucked out yeah that's a good
yeah she lucked out you lucked out what
are you like you know yeah people are
[ __ ] getting shot right now yeah well
but it's all relative they're not gonna
like oh there's some random person that
gets shot you know no I know I know I
know I get it bro it is sometimes
frustrating but you can kind of
delineate the difference between
somebody who actually gives a [ __ ] and
then just some like thought that's like
oh my God I love Heath Ledger yeah
that's like you like The Joker you
[ __ ] idiot yeah uh that was funny
when you said they're all relatives yeah
I know but it went on it that's why I
wanted to call it out thank you you know
all right uh yeah let's do the next one
I guess
oh yeah
what's up Matt and Chris so Chris just
saw you in DC shows rad uh we did a meet
and greet afterwards the picture was
sick for the review of the picture
afterwards I realized you had a Sharpie
in your hand and I was just like messed
it up opportunity Miss I got to send my
Jordan Ones or something but I was too
concerned with chopping it up with you
and having a moment which I remember
this guy so leads me to my question how
do you prefer meet and greets to go and
then Matt if somebody rolls up on you in
public or spots you somewhere because
the show is that it's so popular yeah
how would you want a fan to interact
with you appreciate you guys looking
forward to the advice I feel like I've
talked about this you do it
uh when it happens uh I just as long as
they don't want to like carry on some
[ __ ] conversation about a thing I
don't really know about or or even worse
something I've talked about on either
this but podcaster previous one uh
sometimes people have seen the American
animal I want to talk about that like
just uh
that like I don't appreciate it but like
nobody not just me nobody wants to stop
and have a long uh even a short
conversation with a stranger full stop
you know what I mean but obviously say
something you're happy to see someone
you care about like these people
appreciate that but like the Only Rule
is never ever while they're eating and
that's what I've always thought even as
a kid like I didn't want to go up to
people that I saw uh
celebrities whatever the [ __ ] while
they're eating people do it all the time
when I'm eating and with my kid it just
seemed wrong yeah yeah uh I I still take
pictures but it's like just if you're
gonna be selfish be selfish like they'll
come up and be like I don't want to
bother you but I you know I I know
you're with your kid and I I know you
hate this it's like oh so you're just
[ __ ] don't like you don't give a [ __ ]
about you'd rather than be a pretender
oblivious though I get that I'd rather
than be like dude can I get a pick yeah
100 less words or what well no because
it's like
I'm I'm not a fool right well
do you know what I mean no but like uh
yeah I don't know there's no I'm not
happy to do the meet and greets I used
to [ __ ] hate doing them and now I
like them and dude I think it has to do
with the CBD and I'm not joking dude I'm
not joking plugging away dude no I'm not
even dude I I don't know what it is I'm
like generally happier and a more
appreciative person maybe it's all the
therapy but I [ __ ] straight up that
but it could be the CBD helping I I
straight up I'm like oh cool I'm engaged
in conversations I like doing meet and
greets I you know I do a hundred each
show which is it takes a long time but
uh it's also good for my yaper it's good
from my pocket do what I do a hundred me
a hundred people each show oh my God but
it keeps my pockets you know fat like a
beetle okay
okay well I mean that's good good for
you people obviously love it I just yeah
I like it I like doing it and I
appreciate it and I remember that guy he
was a nice guy just be nice just be nice
as long as you're nice just be nice hey
bro we need to get a pick none of that
[ __ ] that drives me to do anything trust
me yeah yeah I'm not do you're not doing
me a favor bro
yeah be nice and be uh deferential yes
that's the word yeah all right cool
hey Matt and Chris
um I'm a big fan I love you guys
depend on you guys thank you so much
um for this podcast my question you know
how men just seem to get better and
sexier as they age or at least a lot of
them do my husband is just getting more
and more beautiful hotter and hotter and
um I'm 45 we are 45 he works at a bar
and I can see I don't go there very
often but when I do I can see how 20 30
year old women are women of all ages how
they look at him and you know they just
wish he would take them home I've seen
them like desperately try to touch him
like as they hand it their credit card
like grab his arm with both hands and
lean into
I'm really insecure to meet anybody as
his wife because I'm just thinking or
they wondering like
there's an attractiveness Gap oh come on
use a babe dude and meanwhile I don't
know just the way I grew up and at the
time period I grew up
um I feel like it's always been a
priority to
look good and be pretty on top of being
a mother and having a career and all
that and I just feel like I want to be
free of that at this age I feel like it
could be my time to relax and not have
to anyway but it's not uh
what do I do
um any advice not necessarily what I do
just any advice
um okay thanks of all people like she's
truly like really pretty but that
doesn't matter even he loves you yeah I
mean first of all I yeah the fact that
she's 45 is crazy she looks way younger
than 45. you wanna do Tit for Tat I
guarantee more guys would sleep with you
than women would sleep no questions
there's no question there's no question
so he works in an environment that lends
itself to that [ __ ] you don't we just
said people are getting drunk at the bar
it's like you know so I understand a
bartender I don't know if he's a
bartender but it's like a thing that
like has like something that goes along
with it it's yeah you going to the bar
is like literally go uh going online and
searching for hate about yourself it's
just you're gonna you're gonna find a
reason to get insecure about it just did
that's his [ __ ] if you trust him great
if you're not Instagram about that great
um and if you're insecure about getting
uh
uh like worse looking it actually kind
of breaks my heart a little bit that you
say like you worry that people think
that there's an attractiveness Gap that
nobody's thinking that nobody's nobody's
thinking that I can tell you right now I
see you and I see your face and nobody's
thinking that nobody saying that I mean
I'm not saying that doesn't exist people
probably do think that about people but
it's not happening I bet it happens way
less than people who are in
relationships think it happens because
everybody's always down on themselves
and up on their partner because they
[ __ ] love them yeah but there's a
version of that that's probably in his
head too but honestly
you don't need to feel that way because
you are a beautiful woman and uh he
loves you and and beauty is uh
beauty is also something that sort of
grows and changes with age from the
point of view of the partner you know
they might not be like ah you're like
you don't look exactly like you did when
you were like [ __ ] 21 or whatever but
you're so many other things now to the
partner as well uh and it's not like you
have a problem in the [ __ ] looks
department so I get where you're coming
from but uh those women
would only be if anything just plain
jealous of you that's it they would want
to be in your position you are at the
top of the pyramid in these women's yes
because you are the one that gets to go
home with him think of him the
horizontal mom but you think it is
what's he doing married to her people
thinking damn I wish I was her you're
the one who gets to [ __ ] you know
back it up right into his midsection
you're the one who gets back it up yeah
you're the one who gets to go to wrong
City with him you're the one who gets to
do the horizontal Mambo you're the one
who gets to 69 with him okay you're the
one who gets to go down I'm in the car
you're driving I had a guy call in or a
session a session with a guy uh who was
like and I'm not gonna get too into it
but he was talking about how he has like
a crisis of confidence and I was like
looking at the guy when he we first
[ __ ] went on zoom and I saw his face
I was like oh this [ __ ] he's so
goddamn handsome and then he's talking
about the crisis I'm like this [ __ ]
guy's like a regular hot guy yeah you
know uh but people when the when it
comes to themselves
they're [ __ ] perspective is so warped
do you know who you are on the outside
you who you are on the inside and you're
on the inside and you don't you know
what I mean like yeah but also they
judge themselves on the outside
incorrectly well yeah well that's what
I'm saying like you don't necessarily
have the brain of somebody
stereotypically or that we would think
has the brain that somebody who comes
with that outside looks like and I said
all those words together and they make
sense it seems because they don't make
sense yes they do if you took a
transcript of it you could read it and
it would all [ __ ] you have to read it
two or three times but I have to do that
when I read [ __ ] done you immediately
have to say he's a genius what I said
made sense I swear the chances of what
you said having made sense are tiny so
torso I didn't say that in any of his
books you're saying tolstar did not say
I swear to God what I just wrote made
sense no in in Russian or whatever
absolutely not even in the Russian
versions absolutely they translate to
English and they didn't have that
absolutely not okay well I'm saying he's
the one that gets to dine on some fried
butterfly and and when you go home with
them right
here
no your husband gets to dine on some
fried butterfly what the [ __ ] is that
you know what fry butterfly is I know
what a butterfly is and I know what
frying something is but what the [ __ ] is
fried butterfly imagine it imagining it
what it looks like an imagine it pink
but then it wouldn't be pink
imagine a fried butterfly and imagine it
pink okay I'm doing it what is it you
know what it is right yeah okay yeah I
get it I get it I get it I get it okay
I got it I got it I got it I got it I
got it I got it so you're the lucky one
you're the winner you win dude yeah this
girl's a winner she won you know
um
I want to see the guy though I mean I
bet he honestly looks in the vicinity of
me sometimes he's nuts yeah yeah he
wants to no he doesn't just rest his
shirt he looks like something cute when
you think you look best uh now oh what
do you mean handsomeness oh and my age
your whole life when do you think you
look back what was your Peak looking I
think I get I actually do think I get
more handsome as I get older you like
five six years ago me I agree every day
is every day five years ago Dude well
you look exactly the same so I know but
I also but there's something about me
behind my face that makes me [ __ ]
incredibly attractive oh I was gonna say
the opposite you look good and then you
look deeper and deeper deeper and then
it's just no no no no no no
um no there's something crazy about me
that just activates [ __ ] all sorts of
men and women but I bet her husband
looks something like me which is crazy
to do it's not true you know what I mean
uh it's nuts to look like she obviously
lives in Denver because of look at her
and the and so we'll find when I go to
Denver which is in November they'll come
to my show and I'll see how hot he is
anyway okay yeah I want to know send
send a pic of the husband or a video In
Motion at the bar something like that a
live photo yeah yeah yeah okay cool all
right let's do it next
what is up Chris and Matt hey love you
guys love the show yeah keep it super
short and simple because I know that's
how my babies love it uh my name is Nate
and I'm a real estate agent here in
Spokane Washington and as an agent all
of my salary and pay comes from
commission which means that if I don't
sell houses I don't get paid and most of
my family understands this and so they
like to support me but recently I found
out my brother listed his home on the
market with another age group and he
didn't even know this agent and also
decided not to tell me and so I had to
find out because one of my clients sent
it to me to go tour it and I had to be
like oh that's my brother's house but I
didn't know that was on the market so
what would you do in this situation what
would you do if your family didn't
support you in your career I also
haven't really confronted them about it
so should I confront him or just let it
go thanks 100 gajillion bajillion
percent confront him and 100 percent
[ __ ]
let them know that that is [ __ ] John
Malkovich
unacceptable Behavior what the [ __ ] is
that first I mean at least let's assume
they're very close but let's assume it's
me and you then that's [ __ ] up if if
that happened between us I would abs and
you were the one that did it I would be
like yo dude what that would be doing
insane if I did that with you but I
would just be like what are you hard on
my sleeve just like what why would you
do that and I would go like this eating
M M's dude don't hate the [ __ ] game
I'm just trying to stack Gaper I mean
then I would absolutely kill you dude
hey dude I know we're blood but when
you're trying to stack a person that
ain't got nothing to do with it jerking
a guy off
uh uh no I mean you absolutely I get the
Heartbreak baby but yeah not only
reserved the right to
uh uh do that you should do that for
your own peace of mind dude that [ __ ]
would make me not even be able to sleep
at night yeah go up to him be like don't
call him don't text him see him and be
like what were you thinking what are you
doing what are you doing you're my
brother why would you do that yes
I mean yeah yes uh but okay what about
you [ __ ]
no hi yes I know this Blazer's too blue
but why did you try to you know what I
mean yeah start with that start with
something that is going to really hook
them in right unite the two of you in
the same boat we both agreed this place
there's two blue I should get a
different one maybe more muted so anyway
why did you yes but what would fill in
the don't just why did you list a house
and it's not is it because of my
Blazer's too blue do you know what I
mean right this isn't a color that
should be a Blazer right it should be
cancer are you saying lead him into the
wrong answer so it gives you the right
there we go right right okay yeah okay
yes and then this Blazer is the the
color of something that would be hanging
on a Christmas tree or something like
that anyway why did you list your house
not with me for for for instance we both
agree that this place there's two blue
now do we also agree that it's shitty
that you did this with the listing yeah
it's 100 yeah because they're both just
they're both equally as obvious let's
list ridiculous things the color of this
Blazer you listed a house and didn't use
me as your real estate agent do you have
any yeah exactly yeah yeah so here here
are the list of very obvious things that
we absolutely agree on right one this
Blazer is way way too blue yes two yeah
you listing a house with a realtor who
is not me yes very very just three the
Holocaust boy Hitler did is very bad yes
and four ballparks if my character was a
character movie I would be the aid to a
politician so yeah let's yes yeah or
just in real life I look like an aide to
a politician yes 100 maybe you thought
yes to give you the benefit of the doubt
maybe you didn't remember right I'm a
real estate agent you looked at me and
thought that is an aid yeah to a
democratic policy Oregon yep you know
what I mean a woman and so yeah oh yeah
yeah
um Democrats without question right
right yeah so uh yeah man you got to
bring it up it is weird if you are close
with them it's especially weird but yeah
you just be like yo why did you do you
not think I'm good at it because you
might say something like off which is
still wrong but you might be like oh
[ __ ] I thought because we were family I
shouldn't have done it and then at least
you could be like oh and he's like I'm
so sorry it might be that but you can
also fix it so so definitely bring it up
just be like oh if it's that he just be
like well of course either way you
should have asked me though it's super
weird why wouldn't you at least come to
me if you thought it was illegal or
something then like just come to me
about it like it would be super weird
like if you were having a a roast of
yourself and [ __ ] Mark Norman was I'm
seeing it you know I'd be like what the
[ __ ] I do like Mark Norman though I mean
yeah he's funny but like you know I'm
your brother
that's a good idea I might do a roast to
myself but Norman host it sounds like a
good idea no no I show up with a blue
blazer all right uh yeah I think that
that's bad dude
that dude that's that is
top level
shitty that your brother did that dude
you know
I just get confused
um
it's you
you did it
what the [ __ ] uh yeah dude I mean you
are 100 right all right gotta gotta
gotta gotta gotta got it gotta gotta
gotta dude gotta gotta gotta gotta bring
it up oh God I gotta got it gotta gotta
got it all right got it gotta bring it
up okay don't do that I don't want you
to be doing that
um isn't that crazy so listen uh we got
the lifeline live show it's October 19th
Matt's birthday show uh 6 p.m Pacific
watch lifeline.com for tickets below
it's in the comments so click on that
the tickets get more expensive as time
goes on so get them now uh a bunch of
people are signing up and you can call
in and we can [ __ ] chat about your
[ __ ] like this real estate Asian guy we
could literally be like hold on how
close yeah yeah yeah it's only 50 it's
only 15 bucks right now yeah yeah right
now gotta get in there dude that's a
good price and in four days it moves up
to a hundred and fifty dollars right you
might want to get in there yeah no it
doesn't but uh we're also surprised we
also have surprises and stuff for it
right that's gonna show his anus
um
so yeah and you also can get one-on-one
advice sessions with Matt at
matdalia.com yeah if you have a question
watch lifeline.com go there send in a
video and there's also a merch get
that's been movementality shits and all
the other things lifelinemerch.com and I
will see you soon Savannah and Raleigh I
will see you soon I've been wearing a
crewneck merch dude it's popping you got
to get that [ __ ] going fast
rap are we done yeah we're done we did
it we did it
thanks guys fancy thank you
for everything
[Music]